this is incredible it is so wild to see
all of you in the same place at the same
time we'll sort of go around the room
here Tom how his isolation bid for you
we've been a real discovery of the fact
that I didn't realize before I had to
learn how to use the washer and dryer I
just figure out you got a you have to
you know but I didn't actually do it
Alison actually did it but she showed me
now I know I now know it's what this is
maybe my inaugural washing cycle though
I'm actually not sure I'm doing I'm
awesome I live in a wonderful place and
I have you know my darling Alison she
and I it's kind of like being on the
road the house doesn't move it's good
thing yeah and a Dakota for you you know
in isolation I think that the amount of
people that I've talked to here it
either starts to really get to you where
you just want to close in or it breeds
creativity and it's inspiring people
what has it been doing for you well I
normally throughout the year I'm
traveling all over the country to a lot
of isolated communities working
primarily with First Nations yeah and
when I'm not working I come home and I
kind of just stay home and do projects
at home but so it's it feels normal I
mean more time to spend with the
grandkids that's right I said Wow Wow
children and yeah I have a project
called demented that I've been working
on just before the pandemic started I
just did my last scene and now even
today been Carib society who at Sousa
which is their society here in Edmonton
works with First Nations people I just
did a PSA for them oh well and life is
secret so yeah keeping busy and you can
see the kids keep me young yes they do I
can only grandkids you started throwing
that around attina for you the
importance of this show and the fact
that it is still on it's still on aptn
and people are still enjoying it and
they're still relating to these stories
what was
about this show that has just made it so
not only timeless but also important
well I think the importance would be the
fact that it was the first show in
Canada to be set in an indigenous
community within an you know largely
indigenous caste and you know and
reflecting you know in northern
community I think that you know that
said what was important was the success
of the show I don't know I don't think
anybody expected it to succeed and to I
know it was a difficult project to get
on air you know so it just had never
been done before and I think that we
just had such a great writing team and
great producers that we just became you
know a really great drama and but it was
you know it was unique in that I think
was the first time Canadians really saw
indigenous people on their screens and
saw us as you know relatable I think is
a good example of maybe one of real
reality examples of art imitating life
and life imitating art I mean it created
a window for people to actually see what
goes on inside of a First Nation
community and the stories that were
portrayed where else actually based on
true stories and Timothy I want to go to
you what have you heard over the years
of I'm sure your fans have mentioned to
you what it was they loved about the
show have you ever been surprised of a
reason why fans love this show have you
ever been taken back by somebody's love
for this show i I would have to say no
well it was such a good show and
everything that you guys just mentioned
was was very very important but within
that within this indigenous community
what became to me the most important and
I think for everyone was
was the stories within that community
the personal stories and you know
regardless of where they may have taken
place in that community in Toronto or on
Mars the the the relationships and the
ongoing relationships and the changes in
those relationships and everything that
happened within this you know very small
confined space was just it was universal
it was not about indigenous people it
was not about isolation it was about
people
[Music]
everybody is people just continue to
resonate like my dad was just talking
about Tim's character like yesterday he
goes it's the stories within there
and also that and also with with you
guys because there is something that
that I don't know it when you sort of
realized that you were such a great
example for people to see themselves
especially for you Tina being you know
an indigenous woman in a lead of a show
which is something that young girls
maybe had never seen before
yeah so what was that what was that like
for you I mean you took it on so
brilliantly and you know sort of you
know grab that flag and and waved it and
you were the example and still are the
example but I imagine that you have not
heard like just the amount of stories
that you've heard from young people
where you were probably the first
example of something that that were they
saw themselves yes what's what's been
interesting in my life about that has
been that as an indigenous woman I had a
lot of fear of authority you know
growing up and I mean to this day I
still have you know I still have a large
gap in terms of trust with you know
policing in Canada and I and so to play
a police
I it was that just was like you know
again it's just like you go into an
acting you just go into the acting mode
whatever you know like for me my has an
actor that that's how I approached it so
to then to see how it like really
impacted you know women that have come
to me all through the years to you know
to tell me that it made a difference in
their life but I know what that feels
like I see some attempt to cardenal
acting and it made me declare a major in
theatre in University and I didn't know
her so you know I get what that is like
and today one of my dearest friends is a
young woman named Christina and she
works in a remote community and she
calls herself north of 60 and you know
leave so I have developed friendships
just through that and Dakota Dakota
there are so many stories of young
actors getting into show business and
you get a hit show you get recognized
you're traveling all over the place and
then you get in trouble and then you get
yeah and then you and then you get in
trouble but you're this such a fantastic
example of you know taking that going
through that and now you you spend your
life giving back so if you can just sort
of take us through these last I don't
even know 15 16 years and and what the
importance of that lesson was for you
but being when when I first started
doing North the 60 there were times
where I was looking over my shoulder
going are the Raiders following me lay
this is what I'm going through in my
life so being able to relate and not
only that the communities that I've been
to all the people who are like Elsie
that's just like my cooking people
saying oh my god I became an RCMP
officer because of Tina keeper or Tom
Jackson the chief i I'm running for and
it just like I just you know it kept I
kept hitting me time and time and time
again just how and more important how
powerful how groundbreaking it was so
taking that step back in
King ax where I was and what I could do
I knew that I had a just as a strong
message for our young people so that's
when I developed going miles and giving
a private acting lessons showing people
the direction and hooking them up with
contacts yeah agents and it was just
instill today and it's still happening
today so I think throughout the time in
the last 16 years it's I really started
living if you will ya know yeah in my
later years I mean yy-you didn't say
later in my young years models that I've
had you know Tom and Tim and yeah I'm
not mean no no no you are in a very
unique Dakota you're in a very unique
position and I'm happy to actually have
you here because when it comes to
individuals who are you know dealing
with sobriety who may need a meeting who
may need a connection self-isolation is
not usually a good mix what do you say
to people right now who may not be
having on that level as easy of a time
as a lot of other people during this
time well number one don't don't
inundate yourself with information
because it causes a complete mind yeah
that people can see it they can bleep
that out their selves with information
all of a sudden little things become big
things and then they start late for
example a friend of mine the friends for
years their son was my best friend and
the father the father has inundated
himself with information to the point
where he's scared to outside now all the
things that were
so small and muta school to the big
picture are now huge and it's just it's
terrifying them so number one I would
say yes
do not inundate yourself with too much
information I shut that down because
when it first happened I was going crazy
but take that time take that time to
breathe in to relax and find out really
who you are like reflect and look at the
things that you love the most because
the things that you love the most are
right around you and this should be the
time where we're able to communicate to
connect with our family with our loved
ones and to really strengthen that bond
in that relationship within each other
so instead of arguing about little
things like look at the big picture and
you know family as a whole and inside
here and I think there's a lot of things
to do I absolutely agree with you
Dakota there's a lot of things that we
can do to create health versus managing
disease yeah let me give you an example
I met a young indigenous woman in
Germany Alison and I went to Germany
this year in February and there was a
woman there she was a jingle dancer and
we asked her why does she dance and she
says well I guess because I can't
forgive and forget she said I can I can
forgive in certain areas but not others
I cannot forget so I danced a sweat I
danced to aucupe I that space in my
being that is occupied by an evil
trickster by toxic trickster and I
replaced that with something joyful and
those things that I cannot forgive they
seem to go away so when we're home what
do you do you create health versus
managing disease do things that make you
sweat
read books read things that are good to
read tell a joke you know the last time
you laugh 200 times in a day was
probably when you're 2 years old the
funny bone relaxed that funny bone and
laugh it's the best medicine in the
world so ever and lastly
if we turn the word love into a verb our
lives will change so leap dance learn
laugh and love it's a social
prescription that replaces a pill
you